[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und guten
Abend Wintersport und Fußball gleich von
Sven Voss auch von mir einen schönen
guten Abend schauen wir auf die Themen
heute
panzerdebatte geht weiter nach
Schützenpanzern wollen einige
ampelpolitiker der Ukraine nun auch den
Leopard Panzer liefern
Beschuss trotz verkündeter Waffenruhe in
der Ukraine wird offenbar auch während
des orthodoxen Weihnachtsfestes weiter
gekämpft
und Gewinner der Vierschanzentournee der
norwegert sich beim Finale in
Bischofshofen erstmals den Gesamtsieg
[Musik]
Kurswechsel sagen die ein Tabubruch die
anderen auf die Ankündigung der
Bundesregierung der Ukraine erstmals
Schützenpanzer zu liefern wie Russland
darauf reagiert darüber sprechen wir
gleich mit unserer korrespondentinnen
Moskau vorher ein genauerer Blick auf
die neuen Waffenlieferungen
etwa 40 Schützenpanzer Marder hat die
Bundesregierung zugesagt auch beim
Flugabwehrsystem Patriot zieht
Deutschland nach und will nun ebenfalls
eine Batterie in der Ukraine schicken
der ukrainische Präsident selenski
bedankte sich in einem Telefonat mit
Kanzler Scholz beendet ist die Debatte
damit aber noch längst nicht Andrea
Maurer berichtet
die Pläne der Bundesregierung werden im
Laufe des Tages konkreter die bis zu 40
schützenpanzermörder sollen aus
Beständen der Bundeswehr und der
Industrie kommen außerdem hat der
Kanzler in Patrick Luftabwehrsystem
zugesagt von dem es bislang hieß es
stünde keins mehr zur Verfügung wir
haben die veränderte Situation a dass
die Amerikaner ihrerseits eine solche
Lieferung ermöglichen da geht es wieder
um den Punkt den ich immer wieder sage
dass wir keine nationalen Alleingänge
machen und eben auf Bitten der
Amerikaner haben wir geguckt ob wir noch
helfen können und haben einen solches
Patrick System jetzt dafür aus
Bundeswehr Beständen wenn wir zur
Verfügung stellen kaum sind Marder und
Patrick beschlossen wächst der Druck
noch mehr zu liefern schwere Kampfpanzer
etwa wie den hochmodernen Leopard 2
Forderung kommen heute aus der Union und
Teilen der Ampel
der zweite Schritt muss auch kommen
nämlich dass das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht der Ukraine
unterstützt wird mit der Lieferung von
Leopard Panzern der Krieg ist Horst ganz
bitteres und tragisches und man muss
alles dafür tun um ihn so schnell wie
möglich zu beenden und wir haben die
Chance in umso schneller zu beenden je
deutlicher wir die Ukraine unterstützen
deshalb ist auch bei den Leopard umso
schneller umso besser die linke
Opposition dagegen sieht im Kanzler
jetzt einen getriebenen kritisiert die
Panzerlieferungen das ist ein weiterer
Schritt für Eskalation wo eine
Beteiligung Deutschlands auf einmal in
diesem Krieg wahrscheinlicher wird denn
eins ist ganz klar diesen Krieg mit
einer Atom macht ist nicht militärisch
zu klären das neue Jahr beginnt mit
einer Wende in der deutschen außen und
Sicherheitspolitik gemeinsam mit den
Verbündeten liefert Deutschland nun
sogenannte moderne Panzer westlicher
Bauer hat die ersten Mörder sollen Ende
März in der Ukraine treffen
fragen wir Nachbar für begann Moskau
fülbe wie reagiert Russland auf die
geplanten neuen Waffenlieferungen
also hier ist ja heute Weihnachten und
vielleicht ist das der Grund dafür dass
es aus dem Kreml bisher keine
offiziellen Reaktionen gibt aber die
russische Botschaft in Berlin die hat
eine Erklärung veröffentlicht und darin
verurteilt sie die deutsche Entscheidung
nennt das Ganze eine Eskalation Berlin
habe da eine moralische Grenze
überschritten die nicht hätte
überschritten werden dürfen heißt es in
dieser Erklärung und das ganze zeige
dass weder Deutschland noch dem Westen
an einer friedlichen Lösung des
Konflikts gelegen sei diese
Anschuldigungen und auch diese
Behauptungen das ist der sich immer
wieder wiederholende Versuch der
russischen Seite den Westen die Schuld
zuzuschieben die Kämpfe in der Ukraine
zu rechtfertigen und auch die heimischen
Publikum hier die vielen Toten
russischen Soldaten zu erklären danke
für beherr und wir hören aus Berlin die
Bundesregierung nimmt die russische
Reaktion zur Kenntnis
welche Waffensysteme kommen überhaupt in
Frage um die Ukraine militärisch zu
unterstützen eine Übersicht über die
verschiedenen panzergattungen die die
westlichen Verbündeten im Einsatz haben
finden sie auf heute.de oder in der ZDF
heute App
eigentlich läuft in der Ukraine seit dem
Mittag die von Moskau einseitig
verkündete Waffenruhe 36 Stunden
Feuerpause wegen des orthodoxen
Weihnachtsfestes aber schon gestern
nannte Kiew das ein heuchlerisches
Ablenkungsmanöver und griff offenbar
heute in den östlichen Gebieten du Hans
und Don jetzt russische Stellungen an
aber auch die russische Seite soll trotz
Waffenruhe Ukrainer bombardiert haben in
einem Wohngebiet von Restaurant im Süden
sei dabei ein Feuerwehrmann ums Leben
gekommen erklärte der zuständige
regional gewonnen war
und vor Ort in Ukraine ist für uns Tim
Krüger tim war von der einseitigen
Waffenruhe dann überhaupt irgendwas zu
spüren
naja es gab hier kurz nach Beginn dieser
einseitigen Waffenruhe Luftalarm in der
gesamten Ukraine das haben wir auch hier
in Kiel wahrgenommen dabei ging es ganz
offenbar um Flugzeuge die über Belarus
aufgestiegen sind aber es ist dann wohl
doch nicht zu Angriffen gekommen es gibt
auch Berichte darüber dass es wie gesagt
Angriffe von beiden Seiten entlang der
Front im Osten und im Süden gibt die wir
aber bisher nicht verifizieren konnten
das heißt also es gab offenbar auch
ukraineische Angriffe aber die Ukraine
hat ja ohnehin diesen Vorstoss nicht als
Geste des guten Willens anerkannt
sondern als etwas das runtersetzen
Russland nur dazu nutzen will um Zeit zu
gewinnen Zeit um mehr Menschen mehr
Truppen mehr Ausrüstung an die Front zu
bringen um dann womöglich danach umso
stärker losschlagen zu können das Ganze
sei reine Propaganda und überhaupt könne
man über eine solche Waffenruhe erst
dann überhaupt nachdenken wenn wirklich
der letzte russische Soldat die
besetzten Gebiete verlassen habe danke
schön Tim Krüger
der 76 Januar traditionell das Datum des
Weihnachtsfestes in der orthodoxen
Kirche auch in der Ukraine immer mehr
Menschen feiern Weihnachten aber bereits
am 25 dezember ein Trend den der
russische Angriffskrieg verstärkt mehr
also als nur der Wechsel eines Datums
wie Tim Krüger berichtet
Igor und Oxana day kochen ihr
traditionelles Weihnachtsessen sie sind
orthodoxe Christen und feiern heute und
morgen wie auch sonst das Weihnachtsfest
in Zukunft aber können Sie sich auch den
25 Dezember vorstellen um sich von
Russland abzugrenzen der Krieg hat
vieles verändert
ich habe früher in Russland gearbeitet
aber jetzt ist mein Verhältnis zu
Russland sehr schlecht denn in jeder
Familie musste jemand flüchten wurde
getötet oder verletzt
noch einmal gegen Igor und axana mit
ihren Kindern an diesen 6 januar in die
Messe immer mehr Ukraine aber wenden
sich von russisch geprägten Traditionen
ab ein Konflikt der auch die beiden
wichtigsten orthodoxen Kirchen in der
Ukraine erreicht hat sie sind gespalten
in einen eher Kiew treuen und einen von
Kritikern als moskana bezeichneten Teil
diese sogenannte ukrainisch-orthodoxe
Kirche gerät dabei zunehmend unter Druck
der Geheimdienst durch erst kürzlich
Kirchen und Klöster Priester wurden
verhaftet ein Verbot wird diskutiert
viele Repräsentanten dieser Kirche die
in Kontakt mit der Kirche in Russland
ist versuchen sogenannte russische
narrative in der Ukraine zu verbreiten
und unterstützen die russische
Aggressionen
die ukrainisch-orthodoxe Kirche habe
sich nach Kriegsbeginn nicht ausreichend
deutlich von Russland distanziert was
diese zurückweist
unsere Kirche ist absolut loyal dem
Staat gegenüber und ab dem ersten Tag
verteidigen wir unser Land
aber egal in welcher Kirche und wann die
Menschen in der Ukraine Weihnachten
feiern richtige Stimmung kommt
angesichts des Krieges ohnehin nicht auf
in den USA liefern sich die Republikaner
innerhalb ihrer Fraktion weiter einen
Machtkampf mit weitreichenden Folgen
nach drei Tagen und nunmehr elf
Abstimmungen hat es ihr Parteikollege
McCarthy bisher nicht geschafft genug
republikanische Stimmen zusammen zu
bekommen um zum Vorsitzende des
Repräsentantenhauses gewählt zu werden
ein historisches Debakel wer die
abtrünnigen sind und was Sie erreichen
wollen zeigt ihm jetzt MRT wissen
Trauer über das was hier am 6 Januar
2021 geschah aber beim Gedenken sind
längst nicht alle Abgeordneten dabei
denn der Umsturz Versuch von damals geht
eigentlich weiter nur drinnen fast alle
der Rebellen die gegen McCarthy Stimmen
hängen Donald Trumps wahllüge an mad
gets aus Florida und seine Mitstreiter
wollen die Macht des Sprechers und der
Chefs in den Ausschüssen brechen sie
sollen nicht mehr bestimmen welche
Gesetze entschieden welche gestoppt
werden
diese Stadt ist zutiefst korrupt auf die
Art und Weise wie Leute Führungsposten
und ausschussvorsätze bekommen um sich
darzustellen
jetzt wollen sie posten von McCarthy und
er verspricht sie jeder Abgeordnete soll
sogar jederzeit ein Misstrauensvotum
beantragen können um den Sprecher zu
stürzen doch weil einige weiter den
abtritt mccartys fordern wächst der
Unmut bei seinen Unterstützern
Geiselnehmer haben wenigstens ein Ziel
und Forderungen wir haben sie fast alle
erfüllt aber sie bleiben bei nein weil
wir eines McCafe aufzugeben nicht
erfüllt haben das ist wie Terrorismus
aber selbst Kritik von Rechten
Fernsehmoderatoren prallt an den
Hardlinern ab die notwendigen 218
Stimmen für McCarthy sein nirgendwo in
Sicht
die meisten Rebellen wissen die Menschen
in ihren Wahlkreisen hinter sich einige
bekamen über 70 Prozent der Stimmen mit
dem Versprechen
Fundamentalopposition zu betreiben seine
Demontage ist dabei im Mittel zum Zweck
denn es geht ihnen noch heute weniger um
Basisdemokratie sie wollen ihre
Ideologie durchsetzen auch gegen die
Mehrheit im Kapitol und am liebsten auch
ohne ihn
elf Mal ist Kevin McCarthy bisher also
gescheitert bei der Wahl zum
Vorsitzenden des
US-Repräsentantenhauses und soeben im
zwölften Anlauf hat es auch wieder nicht
geklappt aber die Front seiner
Gegnerinnen und Gegner bröckelt doch
noch reicht es für McCafe nicht
kurz vor dem Besuch von US-Präsident
beiden in Mexiko sollen dort bei
gewaltsam Auseinandersetzungen
mindestens 29 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen sein
mutmaßliche Bandenmitglieder lieferten
sich heftige Kämpfe mit Polizei und
Streitkräften Auslöser ein Sohn des
Drogenbosses Gussmann wurde festgenommen
wie schon 2019 sein Vater der auch El
Chapo genannt wird sitzt in den USA in
Haft der Sohn soll Teile des
Drogenkartells weitergeführt haben
eine Meldung aus der Wirtschaft die
Inflation in der Eurozone hat sich im
Dezember abgeschwächt und das stärker
als erwartet die Verbraucherpreise
stiegen gegenüber dem Vorjahresmonat um
9,2% meldet das europäische Statistikamt
laut einer ersten Schätzung im November
waren es noch 10,1%
. in Deutschland kämpft die FDP gegen
sinkende Umfragewerte auf ihrem
traditionellen drei königstreffen in
Stuttgart sagte Parteichef Lindner die
Koalition müsse weniger auf Umverteilung
setzen und mehr auf Wachstum dafür nehme
die FDP auch Konflikte mit dem Partnern
in Kauf wie die FDP sich in der Ampel
noch stärker profilieren will berichtet
Sven Klaas
seine Rede ist gerade mal eine gute
Minute alt da unterbricht Christian
Lindner
klimaaktivisten protestieren im Saal
gegen die Politik der FDP wie zuvor auch
schon draußen die FDP aus ihrer Sicht
blockiere beim Klimaschutz innerhalb der
Bundesregierung Lindner sieht das
erwartungsgemäß anders betont man habe
auch ansonsten viel bewegt in der Ampel
bei aller Kritik wir haben unser Land
bisher gut durch diese besondere
Krisenzeit geführt doch nicht wenige
hadern mit der Koalition im Bund die FDP
leide in der Ampel findet etwa der
Fraktionsvorsitzende aus
Baden-Württemberg auch die FDP Wähler
sind mehrheitlich unzufrieden mit der
Ampel die Basis sieht es so unsere
Herausforderung gerade mit den zwei
linken Parteien aber wir sind auf einem
guten Weg ein paar mehr gelbe Flecken in
der Ampelkoalition tun nicht werden
verkehrt das ist natürlich auch
aufpassen dass wir als Freie Demokraten
und auch als Junge Liberale unser
liberales freiheitliches Profil
beibehalten und nicht verlieren es
dürfte ein Spagat für die FDP werden
zwischen eigenen parteiprofil und der
Notwendigkeit von Kompromissen in
Regierung die FDP denkt etwa laut über
eine längere Laufzeit von
Atomkraftwerken nach will
Steuersenkungen statt Steuererhöhungen
weitere Streitigkeiten innerhalb der
Ampel sind der programmiert wir haben
die Leidenschaft Deutschland voran zu
bringen allen Schwierigkeiten zum Trotz
die FDP will Stärke zeigen in Zeiten
schlechter Umfragewerte vier
Landtagswahlen stehen dieses Jahr an
unterdessen versucht sich die
CSU-Landesgruppe im Bundestag in der
Opposition zu profilieren auch sie
trifft sich derzeit zur traditionellen
winterklausur und zwar im
oberbayerischen Kloster Seeon mit dabei
Bayerns Ministerpräsident Söder der auch
versuchte die Partei auf die
Landtagswahl im Herbst einzustimmen und
die Bundesregierung deutlich kritisierte
über das Treffen berichtet Stefan
leifert die Idylle ist die alte doch die
Rolle noch immer eine neue CSU
winterklausur das war lange der
Jahresauftakt einer Berliner
Regierungspartei heute muss sich die CSU
als Opposition Gehör verschaffen und
arbeitet sich an der Ampel ab heute der
glücklosen Verteidigungsministerin
dort ist im ganzen Jahr nichts richtig
gelaufen Panne über Panne ich wundere
mich dass die
Bundesverteidigungsminister nicht von
sich selbst sagt sie hört auf mein
Gefühl ist vor Lambrecht klebt mehr an
dem Amt als mancher am Boden
Führungsschwäche wirft Söder dem Kanzler
vor ob gaspreisdeckel oder gasumlage
Energiesicherheit oder Panzerlieferungen
die Ampel führen nicht Deutschland ist
nicht der kranke Mann Europas aber
irgendwie der einsame
denn wir müssen immer zum sozusagen
getragen werden zu der Entscheidung
andere sind die Schrittmacher in Europa
wir laufen hinterher auch die Berliner
Silvester trafalle finden wieder Hall in
der CSU sie droht mit weniger Geld aus
dem Länderfinanzausgleich wenn Berlin es
nicht schaffe für Recht und Ordnung zu
sorgen dieses Verhalten dass wir sehen
auch von der Politik in Berlin das darf
schlichtweg keine Links grüne Blaupause
für Deutschland sein
2023 wird für die CSU selbst zur
Bewährungsprobe bei den Landtagswahlen
im Herbst erwarten viele csuhler vom
Parteichef ein Ergebnis und 40 Prozent
in der CSU macht sich Nervosität breit
nur mit einem starken Ergebnis in Bayern
würde sie ihre Bedeutung in Berlin waren
dabei allein auf Ampel Bashing zu setzen
wäre eine riskante Strategie
jetzt zur Erderwärmung und ihren Folgen
bis zum Ende des Jahrhunderts wird rund
die Hälfte der Gletscher verschwunden
sein ergab die bislang umfassendste
Studie zum Thema
in vielen Regionen etwa den Alpen wird
es dann überhaupt keine Gletscher mehr
geben vermuten die Forschenden und
rechnen mit gravierenden Folgen etwa der
Überschwemmung von Küstengebieten weil
der Meeresspiegel bis zu 15 cm ansteigen
könnte oder mit Wasserknappheit in
Dürrephasen die Studie stellt aber auch
klar jedes Zehntel Grad weniger
Erderwärmung zeigt in den Modellen eine
messbare Abmilderung der
Gletscherschmelze
das Kinder viel bewegen können beweisen
die Sternsinger jedes Jahr aufs Neue
seit 1959 sammeln sie Geld für
Kinderschutzprojekte bis dato stolze
1,27 Milliarden Euro andere königstag
klopften die Sternsinger bei
Bundespräsident Steinmeier an
unterließen an der Tür von Schloss
Bellevue den Segen CMB da steht für
Christus segne dieses Haus die Spenden
auch die des Bundespräsidenten kommen
dieses Mal vor einem schutzbedürftigen
Kindern in Indonesien zu Gute
[Musik]
ja und gerade eben ist ja die
Vierschanzentournee zu Ende gegangen
Sven mit einem verdienten Sieger ja und
der wollte es irgendwie auch gar nicht
mehr spannend machen Halver Etna granery
heißt der Sieger der 71 Tournee in
Bischofshofen veredelte der Norweger
seinen Triumph mit seinem dritten
tageskrieg
auch beim letzten Springen ist der
Norweger eine Klasse für sich mit 139
und 143 einhalb Metern distanziert er
die Konkurrenz ein weiteres Mal drei
Siege ein zweiter Platz nur ganz knapp
verpasste den vierten grenzlern der
Tournee Geschichte in Bischofshofen
landet kein Deutscher Springer in den
Top 10 bester erneut der Junge Philipp
Reimund als 12ter jetzt kann ich auch
mal sagen ich war mehrmals bester
Deutscher
hätte aber dass jemand vor mir zu mir
gesagt ich hätte nicht geglaubt
insgesamt ist diese 71 Ausgabe aber
trotzdem eine enttäuschende aus
deutscher Sicht denn auch in der
Gesamtwertung liegt am Ende kein
DSV-Adler unter den besten Zehn
er wird erster norwegischer tournieriger
seit 16 Jahren vor dem Polen kopatzki
und dem Slowenen lanycheck
beim mixedwettkampf in der Nordischen
Kombination führte Jürgen gorbak das
norwegische Team auf Platz 1 das
deutsche Quartett mit Jenny Nowak
Natalie Armbruster Manuel Feist und
Schlussläufer Julian Schmid landete in
Orthopäde auf einem guten zweiten Platz
vor Österreich
gleich drei Norweger standen im ersten
Biathlon Weltcup-Rennen des Jahres ganz
oben beim Sieg von Johannes Bö in
Pokljuka zeigte auch Benedikt doll eine
ansprechende Leistung ein Fehler beim
letzten Schießen kostete ihn das Podest
am Ende fehlten doll knapp 8 Sekunden er
landete auf Platz 4
in 14 Tagen eröffnen die Bayern den 16
Bundesliga-Spieltag gegen Leipzig heute
ging es für den Rekordmeister ins
Trainingslager mit dabei in Doha auch
der niederländische Neuzugang daily
blind der 32-Jährige kam ablösefrei von
Ajax Amsterdam für den BVB dagegen hieß
es Abflug nach Marbella
erfreulicherweise ist auch Sebastian
Alea nach zwei Krebsoperationen und
Chemotherapie wieder mit an Bord
schöne Nachricht das war's vom Sport
es bleibt weiterhin viel zu mild für die
Jahreszeit mehr dazu gleich beim Wetter
von besten Kelly das heute journal
können Sie in diesem Abend um 22:40 Uhr
mit Anne Gerling ich wünsche Ihnen noch
ein schönes Wochenende auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter eigentlich müsste
es Anfang Januar viel kälter sein ist es
aber nicht denn immer wieder kommt Tiefs
und die lenken Warmluft aus dem
Südwesten heran so steigen die
Temperaturen wieder kräftig an zumindest
gibt es beim Regen eine kurze Pause es
bleibt morgen größtenteils trocken in
der Nacht bekommen wir noch etwas Regen
das verlagert sich ostwärts das wird
nicht mehr viel sein im Süden bildet
sich in Gewässer Nähe Nebel und die
Temperaturen sinken auf -3 Grad am
Alpenrand und 10 Grad ganz im Westen
Deutschlands und morgen dann viel
Sonnenschein vor allem wenn der Nebel
dann verschwindet und das wird im Süden
dann länger dauern etwa bis mittags
ansonsten viele Wolken nach Nordosten
hin aber insgesamt trockenes Wetter bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 4 Grad im
Dauernebel im Süden und 14 Grad am
Oberrhein
die nächsten Tage es gibt wieder neuen
Regen von Westen her der dehnt sich dann
in der Nacht auf Montag nach Nordosten
hinaus drei bis zwölf Grad danach nicht
mehr ganz so mild aber vom Winter immer
noch keine Spur ein schönen Abend